and we've heard earlier how the uk is
being urged to invest more into
artificial meat to help tackle the
climate crisis and we've been asking on
social media if you would swap out your
burger for lab-grown meat and around
three-quarters of you said that you
wouldn't claudia carter for example said
she simply doesn't if she doesn't simply
doesn't eat meat if she wants a
vegetarian meal instead of buying an
artificially produced substitute and if
you want to join the debate
please do use the
daily climate show or you can tweet us
at sky news so julia what's your view on
this i know some people are turned off
by the idea of lab grown mead
in fact for example the french minister
of agriculture
has said a meat comes from life not
laboratory so what's your take on it
well i don't really have a petite i
certainly don't have a philosophical
feeling around it in that way i just i
look at the numbers and i think in terms
of practically speaking you know we're
almost at eight billion people on this
planet we're going to be at 10 billion
by 2050 those are a lot of mouths to
feed people need protein we need to do
it differently uh and as we know you
know
the sort of
certainly the the meat the dairy
particularly the beef
industry is responsible for so much
methane and i will you know i will say
actually you know eu's farm animals
produce more emissions than cars and
vans combined so you know we need to
find a better way of eating george
monbiot i know you've done a lot of work
in this area what difference do you
think that artificial meat could make
when it comes to tackling climate change
we could massively lower emissions i
mean i think the most important
technology actually is not so much the
artificial or cultured meat but it's the
it's a the feedstock that you use and
and precision fermentation
using bacteria to create proteins and
fats um bacteria which don't even need
any agricultural feedstock at all
because um for instance the ones which
oxygenate hydrogen
they don't need photosynthesis they're
basically just using carbon dioxide
water and electricity to make protein
and fat and you've minimized the land
area you're using hardly any land you're
using far lower resources to produce fat
and protein which can then be turned
into the million things that we eat
already plus a million things we haven't
even conceived of at the moment and when
you compare that to your chicken broiler
shed or your industrial concentrated
pork production with their immense
cruelty their really disgusting
nature swimming around in feces lots and
contamination you know really you know
that clean meat and the clean
substitutes for it it's very hard to see
how those are less appealing than than
the things they're meant to replace